while politeness is of course always
preferable to rudeness
there are ways of being polite that
badly missed the mark and can leave us
feeling oddly detached and dissatisfied
picture the person who ends up despite
their best efforts seeming what we can
call coldly polite they may be extremely
keen to please those they're seeing they
obey all the rules of etiquette they
offer their guests drinks ask them
questions about that journey suggest
they might want a little more gravy
remark on the interest of a recent Prize
winning novel and yet they never managed
to make their hospitality feel either
engaging or memorable it may be a long
time before another meeting with them is
suggested by contrast there is the
person we recognize as a warm who
follows the cold person in the basic
principles of politeness but manages to
add a critical emotionally comforting
ingredient to their manner they might
when we have an evening planned with
them suggest making toasted cheese
sandwiches at their place rather than
going out to a restaurant they might
chat to us through the bathroom door put
on the songs they love dancing to when
they were 14 plump up a cushion and slot
it behind our back confess to feeling
intimidated by a mutual acquaintance
bring us a posy of daisies or a card
they made call us up when we're down
with the flu and ask how our ears are
feeling mentioned they liked our haircut
and then when we spill something or fart
by mistake exclaim I'm so glad you did
that it's usually me beneath the
difference between the warm and the cold
person lies a contrasting vision of
human nature broadly the cold person is
operating with an implicit view that
those they're attempting to please our
creatures endowed only with the highest
needs as a result all kinds of
assumptions are made about them that
they're interested exclusively in
so-called serious topics especially art
and politics that they will appreciate a
degree of formality in dining and
sitting that they will be strong
self-contained and mature enough never
to have any hunger for reassurance or
coziness and they will be without urgent
physical vulnerabilities and drives
which might prove deeply offensive if
they were mentioned these higher beings
would the cold host believe
wince if someone suggested they curl up
on the sofa with a blanket or handed
them a copy of a magazine about film
stars when they headed for the bathroom
yet the warmly polite person is always
deeply aware that the stranger
irrespective of their status or outward
dignity is a highly needy fragile
confused appetitive and susceptible
creature and they know this about the
stranger because they never forget this
about themselves
warmly polite people have much in common
with a character kanga that tenderly
maternal kangaroo in AML's Winnie the
Pooh books in one of the stories the
little animals are deeply disconcerted
by the arrival in the Hundred Acre Wood
of Tigger
whose very big very loud and bouncy and
assertive they treat him with caution
and are we might say coldly polite but
when Tigger finally meets kanga she's
immediately warm with him she thinks of
him in much the same terms as she does
her own child Roo just because an animal
is large it doesn't mean he doesn't want
kindness however big Tigger seems to be
remember that he wants as much kindness
as Roo says kanga in what might be a
definition of the essence of the
philosophy of warmth sometimes it's
deeply generous to think that another
person may be more elevated than us
collectively we've taken this thought
very much to heart we've internalized
distance and learned caution moving on
from the naivety of the small child who
wanders sweetly when you're sad if you
might like to sniff their grimy blanket
but the warm person knows that however
solid and dignified someone appears on
the outside behind the scenes they will
inevitably be a struggling self
potentially awkward easily bemused beset
by physical appetites on the verge of
loneliness and frequently in need of
nothing more subtle or elevated than a
cheese sandwich a glass of milk and a
hug
you